hello there everyone
um this is mike jordan i'm recording my
talk here in berkeley california
i just like to say at the outset thank
you to the organizers for inviting me
but i was really looking forward to
coming to ethiopia and very sad that i'm
not able to do that
so it turns out here in berkeley there
are some ethiopian restaurants that are
really pretty good
so tonight i'm going to do a take out
from from one of them fienfine
and try to simulate what it would have
been like to be in um in addis ababa
um so my talks about decision making and
and machine learning
um so my perspective on ai and machine
learning is perhaps a little bit unusual
so i'd like to say a couple words about
that
um one way to think about ai and machine
learning is that it's
the attempt to replicate human
intelligence
and to create in a computer the um the
ability to think perceive and act like a
human
um then once having done that we put
these new entities out in the world and
they interact with us and
that may be interesting it may be
exciting it may be
scary um a different way to think about
what's happening
is that we're trying to create planetary
scale systems that do things that help
humans
at scale so think about commerce
or think in the current era about the
medical system
um or think about transportation so
these are systems that involve humans
and they involve computers
involve data flows and they involve
decisions
um they involve ideally learning and
more and more they are
learning and personalization uh so the
principles to build those kind of
systems are a little bit
mysterious right now and we're not
necessarily doing a great job when
people build these kind of systems
so i think this is very much analogous
to the other eras of engineering so
think of chemical engineering it
developed in the 40s and 50s
and before that there was chemistry
there was fluid flow
so there was an ability to understand
some of the ingredients but
the ability to build then a factory that
would have
the right scaling the thermodynamics at
that scale that it would
be economically viable and actually work
and create product
that it wouldn't explode and so on
though that was a mystery
so a whole field emerged called chemical
engineering
similarly for electricity there was
understanding of maxwell's equations and
you know the ingredients in the the
underlying science was clear
but there needed to be a field
developing called now called
electrical engineering that that worked
out ideas like impedance or circuit
design and so on so that you could
actually string
wires across the country and electrify
it and bring it into our homes and have
it be safe
and not burn down the house so i hope
you see some parallel right now we're
trying to build systems that involve
data and data flows across the planet
involving many people
not just one computer with one person
um such that the overall system works
and is predictable
and is safe and is even in some ways
interesting it makes human life better
so as part of that it's not enough just
to think about the pattern recognition
and the representations
it's not enough just to take label data
sets and predict something that's in a
visual scene
you have to think really hard and deeply
about all the decision making that's
going on not just
by one organism or one computer but an
interlocked set of decisions in some
kind of
overall system okay so if this
perspective is at all
reasonable there should be some
historical
argument for it it's not just an
academic phenomenon and i think there
clearly is
machine learning emerged
as a real world phenomenon already by
the 1990s
the back end of companies like
amazon.com
had to do fraud detection um so they
could do commerce at scale
they had to do a particular supply chain
management so if you're going to serve
now billions of products to hundreds of
millions of people
um you have to put the products together
and you have to predict how long it's
going to take
uh on a planetary scale for these things
to to work out to arrive
for each product to arrive at a person
within a day or two
so that went on for a decade and uh it
was it involved computers
large numbers of them the the beginnings
of the cloud
it involved algorithms mostly random
forests but others
other algorithms even neural nets and
involved huge amounts of data and
involved hundreds of engineers
so not that different from the current
era really
um i think the next era was where people
realized that a lot of the data had to
do with um
humans there was human uh transactions
and human desires and values inside of
these data
so you could use the same back-end to
start to
offer new services to humans things like
recommendation systems and other forms
of e-commerce emerged
so i think these were major major
developments in the field of machine
learning
thought of as a system-building field in
the
real world um involving data and
decisions
uh the third generation is what we're in
now um
it's what i think of as pattern
recognition
so neural nets are driving this and all
the compute and data behind that
um i think though it's just pattern
recognition and
that doesn't mean it's i don't want to
minimize the importance of it so you can
now do things like speech recognition
computer vision and translation
still in some limited limited ways but
enough to make it a commodity and make
it useful for business and
and change the world it'll still be a
while until we really see the
the full-scale industrial revolution out
of that um
but i think in the meantime there's
something else emerging which is even
broader and bigger
and it's diluted to it's the large-scale
networks of decisions and data
and flows among all of these at a
planetary scale
um so that's what i want to dig to it is
talk i put the word markets there
um because i think this is gonna involve
concepts and principles out of game
theory market design and so on and not
just
gradient descent optimization and
uh so the rest of my talk goes something
like this i'm going to take a talk a
little more about decision making and
learning systems
and i may give some little vignettes
that give a flavor of the kind of
research you can do if you're thinking
more about the decision-making side um
and less perhaps about the pattern
recognition side which is in pretty good
shape
the decision making side may be less so
so we'll talk a little bit about
reinforcement learning where you're
making
sorry about competing bandits where
you're making um one decision at a time
and you don't know which is the best
decision but we'll put that in a market
context
we'll talk a little about sequences of
decisions um
then we're going to talk about bags of
decisions in the false discovery
context and then i'm going to talk a
little bit about architectures and how
do you build systems that really
might work at planetary scape
um so let's talk about decisions um you
might be forgiven of
you know the if you're thinking that a
decision is really just the threshold
limit output of a neural net
um so but do a thought experiment
imagine that you've just gone to your
doctor
and um doctor measures all kinds of
things about your body maybe even
uh sequences your genome and maybe a 50
000 dimensional feature vector goes into
some
large learning system that's been
trained with all the world's medical
knowledge
um it's a predictor of some kind and
maybe even a very good predictor
but let's suppose the output of this
journal net
if some value is output and it's above a
0.7
that suggests that you're about ready to
have a liver failure and you probably
ought to have an operation and maybe get
a transplant
now your value might be 0.701 are you
just going to trust that and imagine
that i can't do anything better because
it's the world's best predictor
no you're not you're gonna just like you
do with a doctor ask some questions have
a dialogue
you're gonna say well first of all
what's the error bar on that um and an
error bar isn't just a little bit of
kind of gaussian uncertainty or
something it's
um well that data may may not be
relevant to me maybe it's old stale data
maybe it's for people that are different
from me
maybe it was a different machine um so
you
you might want to then have a whole dial
about what if experiments what if i were
to
have a different machine or whether if i
were to change my exercise pattern
or whatever my diet or whatever and
those are a little bit
like causal inference problems you might
want to bring some other data to bear
you might want to take away some of the
data that was originally used in the
building of that neural net
okay so whenever you have real world
decisions with consequences life and
death
things like provenance and counter
factuals and relevance and whole
dialogue start to come to play
it's rarely just that you take a single
output of a single learning system no
matter how good it is and treat that as
as the truth you want to build around
that
moreover it's never really just a single
decision i'm going to make many
decisions today
and there's going to be sets of
decisions that i need to have some kind
of control
of the overall rate on that set of
decisions they might
relate to each other in some ways it
doesn't even just have to be my
decisions it can be
decisions involving other people um it
can be over a network and it can be over
time
and even over large stretches of time
like in the medical sort of situation
um so whenever you have situations like
this you also start to talk about
decisions in the context of other
decision makers so now we need to bring
in some economics there might be
scarcity
i can't do exactly what i want because
other people are doing that and there's
a limitation
there might be competition if i make a
certain decision
i know you'll make a decision on the
basis of that and that means it's not
even worthwhile to have made that
decision in the first place and if i
start to think that through i'm doing
game theory
and that's what you really have to do in
the real world when you start making
decisions
it's not just that a learning system
figured out the right decision based on
some data
there's a whole interaction going on
moreover a lot of this is just going to
come up in the moment
um if you tell me i have liver disease i
may think of something from my past
that's relevant but was never kind of
brought in as data in in the original
decision making
and that's going to happen all the time
the context is going to condition how i
react to situations
all right so um sort of to broaden this
uh perspective
we can think about markets as decisional
centralized algorithms this is not a new
idea it's been around for a while it's
just not really coming
fully into the machine learning
literature or the machine learning
consciousness that we should also be
using market principles as part of our
decision making in a learning system
okay these systems a market can be
adaptive it can be robust
it's scalable and they can have a very
long lifetime
um decades or centuries uh so these
concepts of adaptive and robust and
scalable and so on those are
those are concepts that underlie
intelligence and so bringing markets
into the learning system learning world
does give us a certain notion of
intelligence that we we don't
necessarily easily get otherwise
now of course markets aren't perfect
they have lots of difficulties some of
which have been studied by
uh economists and some of which haven't
yet because we not really thought a lot
about learning
and together with markets and
large-scale systems so there's gonna be
all kinds of new research opportunities
emerging
so let me give you a little bit of a
thought experiment that kind of helped
me move more in this direction i was
thinking about recommendation systems
you all know what they are you keep a
record of customers purchases and you
use those to make recommendations to
other customers
all right now classically this was done
in you know
just with a learning system that took in
data and made an analysis of it and then
try to give out its best prediction
of what a customer might like um and
that's fine if you're doing
certain kinds of products um suppose
you're recommending movies
the classical instance of this well um
i might recommend a movie to one person
and then later in the day i recommend
um the same movie to another person and
i could recommend the same movie to
hundreds of thousands of people if i'm
if
my system is really working at scale and
there's no problem because i can just
copy the movie and send it to everybody
and that's sort of true for books as
well you can copy the book
as much as you want nowadays but it's
not true when you go into other domains
so if you think about a recommendation
system for restaurants
um it might recommend the same
restaurant to 10
000 people if it's being used in a city
say the size of shanghai
um and uh those people are going to be
unhappy if they go there and they find
there's a long line
and fixing this is not easy or it's not
it's not easy
if you don't think about a market if you
think about how to balance
so that some people are sent to that
restaurant and others not
you really need to think about well why
should i send that person to that
restaurant do they just like that
other restaurant better but you can't
know that that person that moment might
have a particular taste or they might
have other people with them and so on so
forth
so really needing an interactive system
not just a learning system
that starts to make recommendations when
there's scarcity and there is scarcity
here i can't put
the same you know i can't put 10 000
people in the same restaurant
um this is a problem that's already came
up what if i recommend
streets to drivers what's the fastest
route to the airport
well if i recommend the fastest route to
every driver and it's the same route
there's gonna be congestion
and it'll no longer be the fastest route
so this is kind of
thinking that's very common in economics
and just less common in machine learning
we think of this as a problem that we
have to fix after we built our system
whereas it should have been in there
from the very beginning
recommending in the financial market
stock purchases if you recommend the
same stock purchase to everyone or to a
large number of people who destabilize
the market
all right so thinking about how to fix
this is is uh really requires some some
market thinking
in some sense it's not all that hard you
really just create a two-way market here
and you have
bids or consumers and producers and
maybe even auction of some kind
uh you have recommendation systems on
both sides of the market so you
are uh drawn towards the relevant
decisions on the other side of the
market if i'm a
diner in shanghai i don't really want to
be uh
offered any possible restaurant of the
maybe hundreds of thousands there's
going to be a subset that are relevant
to me based on my past
similarly on the other side of the
market um
and now if a restaurant offers a seat to
me because i pulled out my cell phone
and said that i'm
interested in dining somewhere and i
accept that offer
there's now economic value that's passed
a bid has been made and i've accepted
and a seat has been occupied so the
market naturally won't uh
over um won't send too many people to
the same restaurant
um the the load balancing is just
handled
and there's all kinds of interesting
then fairness and long tail sorts of
issues that are really worth
thinking about here and it is a learning
problem especially because there's these
recommendation systems in there
um if it wasn't if it was just a huge
game table this would not scale
and it really wouldn't work very well
because it wouldn't take into account
people's
people's preferences uh give another
example my favorite one
uh has to do with music and the data age
so more people are making
uh music than ever before right now and
more people are listening to it than
ever before
so you it's in a real explosion you
would think that there's a amazing
market behind this and a lot of people
are
having a livelihood making money out of
this
and that's that's just not true um so
there is an old legacy
set of record companies that pick out a
few musicians make them
very very wealthy and very popular um
and many other people are not
picked out by this system and the
interesting
aspect of this is that if you look at
the data
most of the music being listened to on a
given day
in most countries is music made in the
last couple of years
first of all and it's not made music
made by the famous people it's music
made by
regular people who are just pretty good
at it and uploaded their songs to some
site like soundcloud
it was then streamed to people people
listened to it but the original maker of
the music is disconnected from that
they're not in a market where they're
making a
you know a direct connection to a
listener and therefore starting to set
up economic value for their product
um so uh you can you know build
streaming systems and then
sell subscriptions or do advertising and
you might make money
but the original musician is not really
in you might give them a little bit of
money but that's not a real market
um so uh again the alternative here is
not that complicated
it brings learning together with markets
so first of all you have to have
information flowing to have a market so
each musician should be given a
dashboard as a little bit of data
analysis will provide that
um where a musician will see a map of
the country they live in at the end of
the week and see every time a song of
theirs has been listened to there's a
little dot
on the dashboard on the map and they
learned that maybe they're really
popular in um
uh in addis ababa and uh then they can
show that to
uh the venue owners in that city and the
venue owners are gonna invite them to
give a concert and they could make you
know
you know twenty thousand dollars or
something um at least in some countries
and at least uh they can start to do
that enough times that they can make an
income
they can actually uh start to have a
career and uh maybe not become rich
but they could actually have a
livelihood doing this offering their
music
now it's not just about going to venues
it's also having merchandise around your
uh your activities
that your uh fans can can buy
it's starting to build a long-term
presence in people's lives you can offer
to play at weddings
you can make a connection so
you know this really uh is missing um
linking of producers to consumers should
be the goal of a lot of our learning
systems
and not just mere uh data analysis i do
want to mention steve stout who's a
a friend of mine uh who uh you know is a
brilliant entrepreneur who's doing this
in the united states even beyond
a company called united masters uh is is
building this kind of linked
two-way market based on data analysis
uh social consequences of this way of
thinking even if it's a simple way of
thinking
is that ai can now create new jobs it's
not just about taking away of jobs by
replacing humans
it's creating new connections between
producers and consumers which may be
humans and maybe machines
but a new market might be created and
markets tend to create wealth
they try to create jobs so music is
clearly a place where this could be done
but
art other forms of entertainment
information services
or someone will make a video for someone
else for a particular purpose
um and so on so um when there's scarcity
there's an opportunity to actually build
a market which takes into account
scarcity
and creates value
so how do you turn all this way of
thinking into research
what kind of research problems emerge if
you start to think this way
um so here are just some examples that
i've been working on
recently there are examples effectively
at the interface between machine
learning and economics
microeconomics game theory market design
so think about multi-way markets in
which the individual agents need to
explore to learn their preferences
a classical game there you assume the
agents knew their preferences
uh maybe the agent has to explore
moreover
maybe there are hundreds of thousands of
entities like restaurants or goods
and an agent is no way going to have a
preference over all those things a
priori
so you have to assume the agent is doing
some exploration
and moreover there's a lot of sparsity
in that so you'll need something like
recommendation systems
and then there's a other kind of
inferential problems in game
theory with uh information asymmetries
one person knows something the other
doesn't
lane variables and and data collection
and strategic settings and so on and so
forth
um so many many problems emerge when you
start to bring microeconomics together
with machine learning
so i'm going to mention just a few
little small vignettes here
of research that we've been doing in my
group that has this flavor
really just to give the audience a bit
of a an idea of problems like this and
what you could do
and what new problems will emerge when
you start to think this way
uh so the first one i want to talk about
is is a project called competing bandits
uh competing bandits in matching markets
um my students lydia liu and joria mania
have worked with me on this
we have a paper in the ai stats
conference this coming year on this
so my favorite learning problem um is
the multi-arm bandit
it's a situation where there's a
decision maker who's trying to decide
between a number of options here we have
three
and um it doesn't know which is the best
so there's no supervised learning
situation here
there's no one telling them a label for
what's the best action so they have to
explore
and try things out and as they explore
they start to learn
that one of the actions might give a
higher reward than the other
and then they start to exploit where
they pick that action more and more
frequently
okay so they're learning about these
things there's a long beautiful
literature on this
and um one of the algorithms that has
emerged out of that
that's particularly worth knowing about
is the upper confidence bound algorithm
where you don't just retain the mean
reward so far
but you retain a confidence interval on
the mean reward
and now when you decide which arm to
pick on the next trial you don't just
pick the best one from the point of view
me reward you take the upper confidence
bound
that has two properties one the upper
constant will probably be high
if the arm is a good one meaning the
overall reward distribution is high
or the upper confidence bound can be
high because you're very uncertain about
the reward on that arm you haven't
experienced it very much
so you have a big interval of
uncertainty and that's another reason to
pick the arm
because you might learn then that it's
not actually such a good arm but you
won't know that
until you pick it a few more times all
right so
this algorithm has a number of beautiful
theoretical properties that has a low
regret
a logarithmic in the number of trials or
perhaps square root depending on the
exact assumptions
um here i show that uh the highest arm
upper confidence bound is being picked
the agent will continue to do that
adapting the uh confidence bounds and um
and moving on now let's put that
together with um
one of my favorite ideas in
microeconomics some matching markets so
we have buyers on one side of the market
and
suppliers or sellers on the other side
of the market
and we assume in classical um
that the buyers have a preference for
the sellers and the sellers have a
preference for the buyers and these are
all known
a matching market is one where we simply
try to give the buyers
the closest a a a seller which
is high in their preference list and
similarly for the sellers
and um we try to find an equilibrium
where
no one can um swap with someone else and
arrive at a matching which is better so
your local moves are not going to
improve things for you
there is a famous algorithm named due to
gail and shapley
which finds such a stable matching um
an efficient algorithm that does that
okay so now let's try to put that
together with
bandits all right so uh it should be
obvious what to do
at least what the problem is um what if
the participants in the market don't
know their preferences are priori
and they only observe by trying things
out in the market
learning what the reward is and then
starting to develop a preference from
that
from those noisy interactions okay
so we now have an exploitation
exploration problem for each
learner but it's in the context of other
learners and their scarcity we can't
give the same
seller to multiple buyers
so here we have now two agents and
they're gonna both pick arms
and let's suppose at some point that
both of them pick the same arm
uh so in our model what happens now is
that one of them will get the arm
the other one gets no reward okay so one
of them gets a reward the other one
doesn't
who gets the reward well the agents uh
on the other side of the market the arms
in this case
have their own preferences back on the
um the
left side of the market uh and so they
may prefer the bear
um and uh the bear gets the reward and
the human does not get the reward here
now if the human starts to observe this
the human might be
thinking that rm2 is really looking good
from the ucd point of view
but realizes that every time it picks
arm two there's a good chance the bear
will also pick it and it's going to lose
the reward in that case
so then start to explore the other arms
more than it would are already done
otherwise done um and it'll pay a little
bit of a hit there in terms of the
exploitation the
the regret will be higher because of the
presence of this other learner in the
system
so you'd like to quantify that in the
context of what we might call a bandit
market
um when we get noisy rewards and we want
to learn our preferences
um uh just kind of briefly here
uh you know i just want to give a little
sense of the results here
um you define first of all a notion of
regret here
and what we do is define that relative
to the best stable match you could have
if you ran the gale sharply on the true
preferences
so how much do you regret relative to
that and
we define an algorithm which is simply a
blend of upper confidence bounds with
gail shapley
so each agent maintains an upper
confidence bound on each of the arms
at each step it sends those upper
confidence bounds to a gail shapley
matching
which then returns a matching and then
the uh the
agents get to experience the arm that
they're matched to
under that algorithm um we're able to
prove an upper bound on regret
and as you can see here it's logarithmic
in the number of steps which is good the
system is learning
it's able to learn the delta squared
there
is the a reward gap that depends on the
other agents
so as i mentioned earlier you'll lose a
little bit in terms you'll have more
regret if there are other agents in the
problem we're able to quantify that with
this
quantity delta which we have an
expression for in the paper
okay all right so um
i also want to say one more thing about
this is that this particular algorithm
has one nice property from a game theory
point of view it's incentive compatible
uh if everyone else is playing this
algorithm in this game
um then i have no incentive to deviate
from that algorithm
okay so that's an interesting connection
to game theory
um a second vignette i'd like to discuss
is a situation where now we don't just
have a single action like we had there
in the context of other decision makers
we now have a sequence of actions aka
the reinforcement learning problem
i just want to mention this in passing
um because we're going to put ucb
together with reinforcement learning and
this is something that which has been
done
a bit in the literature but less than
you might think trying to think of
regret balance for reinforcement
learning uh by adding ucb
into it and reinforcement so we're going
to particularly look at q learning
and ask what happens when we add upper
confidence bounds to q values
so this is joint work with uh chi jan
jayan alan zhu and sebastian bubeck
um just briefly you'll all know what
reinforcement learning is here so let me
not get into a review of that we have an
mdp
with states actions and rewards um
and there's a lot of discussion in the
literature about model based versus
model-free versions of this
in the model-based version you would
learn a transition model
and then you build a planner by and
analyzing the transition model
and the model 3 approach you would
somehow directly find a policy
and never form a model of the
transitions and there's debate about
which is best
um you know and and under various
assumptions
um so what we have done here is to to
enter into this debate
by adding exploration because you have
to explore if you're going to do model
based and you have to explore if you do
policy based
so let's actually put it into the theory
that we have the expiration side of it
and so uh very briefly um just to
put on one slide the algorithm we've
analyzed this is just q learning
with an upper confidence bound and so
again not getting the details but if you
know q learning you'll recognize in blue
there the q learning
algorithm updates um and we're adding an
expiration bonus which is coming from
this upper confidence bound bt
and it scales in a particular way with
the parameters of the problem as shown
below
adding that and this is different from
epsilon greedy where you simply
uh choose an action um by maybe ultimate
distribution this is a more targeted way
to choose the action
all right so i'm not going to get any
details here but this is a
sequence of theoretical papers on on cue
learning oh sorry reinforcement learning
um and you can see the the regret
analyses here
for model based there's a sequence of
papers which show that you get
regret that goes to square root of t
capital t which is the number of rounds
of the uh
um uh the learning uh experience
before our work which is shaded there uh
the model-free
systems we had much worse regret but
here we see that you can get actual
square root of t
regret with q learning if you add the
ucb component of it
all right so ucb is important for this
for q-learning to actually hone in on
the right policy quickly
uh as part of the exploration and
exploitation trade-off
all right um just uh
two more uh parts of my talk and i'll be
done um
so this is a topic that is near and dear
to my heart i've been working on this
with aditya ramdas and tiana zurnich in
the last few years
this is where we're not just making one
decision at a time
it's not where we're doing sequences of
decisions like the reinforcement
learning it's where we're doing bags of
decisions
and it could be not just one agent could
be a whole networked set of agents
um and we're where the overall group is
making large numbers of decisions
and we want the overall fraction of good
decisions to be high
um this line of research is uh tradition
in statistics
uh going back to the original discovery
false discovery rate by benjamini
and hochberg back in the 1990s and then
this anytime idea
is um is is new um
beginning with foster and stein in 2008
and then various other authors
um so anytime here simply means we'd
like to have an air rate at any point in
time
that you're making decisions
asynchronously over time
i want to be able to stop you and ask
how many decisions have you made up
until now
what fraction of those are good
decisions and i want that fraction to be
high
no matter what time i stop you even if i
stop you anytime during your whole
lifetime
okay so is that even possible
so let's talk just a little bit about
multiple decisions um
this is a tutorial if you're a
statistician
but machine learning has not really
embraced this as much as you might
have hoped so i want to make sure that
all of you hear a bit about multiple
decisions
so this is a well-known cartoon that
brings
the problem out in an amusing way so
here i have a
person who's discovered a phenomenon or
has a hypothesis
the hypothesis that jelly beans cause
acne so a particular
candy if you eat it causes a skin
condition
um so someone asked scientists to
investigate
what that will probably mean is doing a
random randomized controlled experiment
where you take 100 people and 50 of them
go into the jelly beans condition and 50
or the non-jelly beans condition
and after a few months go by you look at
the people who ate the jelly beans
versus those who didn't
and you asked is the skin condition
different in the two groups
um and if you did this uh with random
assignments you can actually calculate a
p-value a probability that even if there
was really no difference
you would find one and here the p-value
might be um
really high so you know that it's uh
unlikely that the difference was
actually due to the jelly beans um all
right now
in classical treatments it just sort of
ends there you
did everything correctly but in real
life you know it never ends there
if you got a null result you you're not
done you probably you're gonna go off
looking for a real result one you could
publish
um if you didn't make any money on the
first one because there's nothing to do
you're going to go looking for something
else that you can actually do so people
will have other hypotheses they'll say
all right it's not just jelly beans it's
a particular color of jelly beans
so now they might go testing all the
different colors of jelly beans purple
and brown and pink and so on so forth
and you know what's going to happen at
some point by chance alone
even if you're using 100 new people at
each for each experiment
um by chance alone 50 the 50 you put in
the jelly beans condition
will already have had bad skin even skin
condition
after six months go by you look at them
you see they have bad skin condition
um and you don't know any better or you
think it's due to the fact they were
eating the jelly beans
so you'll get a p-value which is less
than 0.05 and you say i've made a
discovery
and the problem is of course you
probably haven't but you have something
you can publish now so you publish it
and everyone's surprised by it so they
even publish in the newspaper because
it's so surprising
so the most surprising results tend to
get amplified
and the problem is is that the most
surprising roots are mostly going to be
the false ones
all right so again if you're a
statistician this is not news to you
what may be news if you're not a
statistician is that you can start to
fix this you can start to develop
procedures which control the false
discovery rate
so let me say a little bit of what that
is um let's imagine i'm not
just doing now one decision at a time
i'm making nine decisions here
and the ones on the left in gray are the
ones where there is no discovery to be
made
um there's no real difference okay so i
should not make a discovery in that case
i should be i should assert that the
null i cannot reject the null
on the right hand side i've got four um
experiments where there
is a discovery made i should say i'm
making a discovery in these four cases
that's p
two five three and six all right
so i run something like a neural net or
some other learning system on this
hypothesis testing system and it's gonna
um
it doesn't know the difference between
the left and the right so on all nine of
these experiments it's gonna make a
decision
let's suppose it says in the four cases
on the bottom that these are discoveries
um
and in the other cases it says no
nothing to discover
okay now we can see here that the
number of discoveries is um
uh four but two of them are actually
false discoveries i shouldn't have made
a discovery
so my fraction of false discoveries over
the total discoveries is two out of four
not too good half the time i'm making an
error all right
now is that something you should worry
about uh well i'll give you an example
here that helps to bring home why you
should worry about this
um so first of all let's define the
false discovery proportion
it's the number of false discoveries
over the number of discoveries
that's a random variable it has a
bayesian interpretation
i'd like it to be small to give this a
frequentest
perspective i might take the expectation
of that and ask on average
that the the fdp be small then that's
called the false discovery rate
and there's a literature starting with
benjamin hochberg algorithms
that attempt to control for this fdr
let me show you a little example here
that hopes to bring
home why controlling fdr can be
important
so let's think about a situation where
i'm running ten thousand different a b
tests so in industry this might happen
all the time
um on a given day you spend a million
dollars and you um run all of these
independent a b tests maybe you're
trying to decide on the website
whether it should be blue or green and
um
i run all these tests it may be the case
that underlyingly 9
900 are true nulls and 100 are nominals
now we don't know that um and this is
pretty typical in a mature science or
technology where most things that you
try out
are not going to be just uh should are
not worthwhile um
pursuing they're not discoveries they
won't really do anything new
um so let's suppose you have a world's
best neural net
and it has a type one error rate of 0.05
i.e false positive rate um and let's
suppose we apply it now to the 9
900 true nulls we multiply 9
900 by 0.05 we get 495 false discovery
so it's pretty good
it's only five percent of the number of
um cases where
i should have said null okay on the
other side
uh the power let's suppose it's high the
neural net when it's supposed to make a
discovery does make a discovery 80
percent of the time
so if i apply that to the hundred
non-nulls i make 80 discoveries
of the hundred non-nulls so i have a
neural net with a very high sensitivity
and specificity or precision recall
however you want to think about it
um is it going to really work well in
practice
uh from the point of view of this um of
these 10 000 different a b tests
the problem is at the end of the day
your boss is going to come in and ask
you how you did and you're going to say
well i ran 10 000 tests
and the bosses could say well what
discoveries did you make because those
are the ones you can act on
um and maybe change the website or do
something else and try to make
a business model out of it so you're
gonna tell the boss that you made
uh 575 discoveries adding those two
numbers up
but unfortunately unbeknownst to you 495
of those are false
so your error rate is 495 divided by
575.
so it's terrible even though you had a
really good neural net with very good
precision recall or sensitivity
specificity
your error rate that really matters to
the boss
which is the fraction of the discoveries
that you made
which fraction of them are actually not
real discoveries that are false
it's really really high it's unbearably
high and so the boss will now take all
of your discoveries and try to implement
them maybe spend some money doing that
and we'll find out later that those were
all uh false discoveries
and you will lose your job all right so
um this is an important problem it can
be resolved with benjamini hochberg
algorithms
under certain assumptions um the problem
that we've worked on
is to do this in an online setting where
you're making discoveries over time
i stop you at any given point in time
and i say
how many discoveries have you made until
now and you say 75
i say well a fraction of those are false
and you say less than five percent
and no matter when i stop you i want you
to be able to say it's less than five
percent of false discoveries
all right so that is possible and here's
just a picture that suggests it
um you're given a error budget in the
beginning if you start to make
um non-discoveries
you start to lose that budget if you
start it at .05 it goes down over time
once you make a discovery i give you a
little bit more budget that you can
spend on future tests
and the reason this is justified is
because the fdp is a ratio
you can make that ratio small in two
ways the numerator can be small
or the denominator can be large and so
making a discovery restores the
denominator and
you can get you can allow yourself to
make more
tests in the future based on that um
okay so we've gone through some
vignettes involving decision making and
learning
this does not by any means exhaust the
set of problems or spam the space in any
way
it's really just meant to give you a
flavor of the interesting kind of
problems you can work on
where you're starting to work on systems
that have maybe just one decision but
there's
competition or you have sequences of
decisions and there's a need to explore
um or you have bags of decisions and
there's a need to
control um error rates over the entire
bag of decisions
all right in my last uh couple of
minutes here
um i'd like to say a little bit about
this
the systems and software side of this
because as i alluded to earlier
i think of this machine learning effort
that we're involved in
is is about building systems it's about
building the same medical system that
would respond well to a pandemic
um the current medical system measures
people's
um health throughout the world it tries
treatments
um and it should be an overall
system where decision making in one part
of the world percolates to other parts
of the world
quickly not simply by ad hoc reports um
and it's vetted and there's provenance
done there's air bars
and it really is a working system like a
chemical factory as a working chemical
factory system
and i hope you all appreciate how much
more complex this is
that it involves uncertainties of all
kinds it involves people it involves
partial observations of data
and so on and so forth um but you know
these are the kind of things that we
should aim to
to solve in our lifetime in our
generation
uh so this project uh is a platform
called ray
which aims to to work in a distributed
sense
focusing on decision making problems in
machine learning
so ray is first and foremost a
distributed system
it's aimed to work either on a single
laptop
um or on thousands of computers or tens
of thousands running on the cloud
and you shouldn't have to change your
software you should be able to write a
program for your laptop
and simply hit a button and it's now
able to run
on as many computers as you're able to
um
to give it um so we motivate this by
considering a current machine learning
ecosystem
which might have um uh
training model serving streaming uh rl
capabilities and so on and so forth
and um in the early days people will
develop this on a single computer but at
some point they want to put it into
production and make it
scalable so what typically happens is
someone to build this distributed
version of whatever already existed
so for each one of these capabilities
there is work
on making distributed versions of these
things certainly including mapreduce
hadoop spark
but also things like clipper tensorflow
serving flink and so on and so forth
what we aim to do in rey is to once and
for all handle the distributed aspects
of these learning problems
pull them into a single system that we
call ray and have all these capabilities
as
libraries on top of ray okay so they
don't have to keep
rewriting the distributed aspects of
this the um
the objects the scheduling and so on and
so forth that's done
in one single system and it's easier to
write and maintain libraries
okay um so that's one way of thinking
about what ray aims to do
the other thing um the other uh
perspective on it
is that it's a distributed form of
python
so python is a language which is uh
prevailing
uh very popular now one of the reasons
is that it provides two core concepts
from programming languages
it's both functional programming and
it's object oriented
um these emerged over the last several
decades these capabilities
there originally were language that had
neither that's what i learned
i was a c programmer then there were
languages were
purely functional and then there was
object oriented and python puts them
both together
when we've gone to the distributed
environment systems
uh such as hadoop and spark which have
been so key
and and being able to do data analysis
at scale
have been functional oriented okay so no
state
map and reduce are functional primitives
so what
ray aims to do is to bring both
functional
programming and object-oriented
programming into the distributed world
so we have tasks and actors which are
the uh distributed versions of functions
and objects
right so ray therefore
takes on this task of making tasks and
actors
uh it builds it on top of a data
structure called dynamic task graphs
where all the hard work
is done to make sure that the
the api of tasks and actors is
simple and usable at the top level uh so
here in fact is an example of the api
um on the left you have uh some python
where you've defined a vector and you've
taken a dot product
what we want to do with ray is simply
say add a decorator to the code
such that we say run this remotely and
then it's free to use whatever
processors it has available to it
you call two vector creators
creating functions here zeros and you do
a dot product
and there's lazy evaluation so when you
call ray.get the actual
numbers are brought back into a register
to a variable result
similarly on the object side actors you
decorate the code and um
here we've taken an object which has
state
decorated it and then we're able to call
it uh without very minimal change to our
code
all right on this slide you're not going
to be still to see the details here but
this is some code to do
a hyper parameter search on a single
computer okay
um the person writing this code wanted
to then run it on a
many many processors and so they changed
this to run on ray and you can see in
red the things that were done there were
some decorators add to run this with ray
um that was it the system ran without
any other changes it ran on ray
so currently we have a broad range of
scalable algorithms that run on top of
ray
you can see some of them there uh
decision oriented particularly
um under the hood there's a great deal
of uh
software uh it does uh various forms of
object stores it manages them um it has
schedulers and it manages all the
processors available and so on
uh so this is being done uh so that the
user doesn't have to think about this
and here's a performance curve of
showing that as you get up to 60 nodes
you can start to get
a roughly a million tasks per second
um just to show an example of this is
being used in
production in certain several companies
around the world here's a particular
company where
they were updating a model once per day
at really really large scale you can see
the the
on the left the cell phone you could
probably guess what company this is
um they updated the model at a great
deal of engineering effort and brought
the click-through rate uh up by five
percent
and got the model updated every hour um
with ray
it was possible to bring the model
updating down to five minutes and the
click-through rate uh went up even
further
um there's a community around this uh
it's open source
you can find it on github in 2019 is a
little bit out of date there
was already um
about 600 000 downloads of ray that's
gone up significantly by now
and there are a number of companies that
are using it contributing to it as part
of open source
development and using it in production
including
banks and financial institutions um
i'm going to finish here just here's a
slide that
shows you where the github project is
we'd welcome anyone who wants to
contribute to this project
many many things to do here um you can
run it on your own laptop or you can
write it in the cloud if you choose
um and i want to recognize my co-authors
there so
philip moritz and robert nishihara have
particularly led this project now for
several years
here at berkeley so let me finish then
just a few parting comments again
popping back up to the top level
machine learning has been uh remarkable
in our era
it is uh leading to new industry
it's um it's changed the face of
computer science and
academia um but it is limited it's uh
it's an era which is focused on pattern
recognition that's a terminology from
dude and heart and others back in the
1960s
it's pattern recognition on steroids um
but it's limited it's just pattern
recognition
um it's a commodity but it's not enough
if you take the decision-making side
seriously
um it's gonna have to be more of a focus
in the future when you make
consequential high-stakes decisions life
or death we need explanations you're
gonna need dialogue about decisions when
you think about sequences and
simultaneous decisions
and then specifically most importantly i
think when you put
learning systems in the context of
overall market mechanisms so you can
build large-scale systems
we're going to have to rethink a lot of
what we've learned about in machine
learning and i'd see this as a several
decade long process
um you know new problems new mechanisms
are going to be needed
even issues like fairness and um uh you
know
uh fair treatment of humans and and so
on has to have a
uh economic side to it we should think
about the values of the people that are
making the decisions
as part of the learning system uh thank
you very much
it's been a pleasure to talk to you